estábamos por concluir el problema 1 de
respuesta abierta del examen de cálculo
up de 2008 ya estábamos en el inciso de
déjame repetir lo que dice dice que la
región r es la superficie de un pequeño
lago en cada uno de los puntos de r que
están a distancia x del eje del h la
profundidad en ese punto está dada por
la función hdx igual a 3 - x con eso hay
que encontrar el volumen del lago aquí a
la derecha había empezado a hacer un
dibujo dibuje la superficie por aquí y
en el vídeo anterior estaba intentando
dibujar la profundidad cuando existe
cero el lago tiene profundidad 3 -0 que
es igual a tres metros digamos y cuando
x es igual a 2 la profundidad es 1
entonces para encontrar el volumen
tenemos que pensar como en los incisos
anteriores vamos a hacer cortes entonces
ahí te va lo que vamos a hacer es
dibujar un corte digamos por aquí
mejor lo voy a hacer con otro color para
que no nos confundamos lo voy a dibujar
en color verde entonces ahí está va
entonces voy a hacer un corte la altura
sobre la superficie va a ser la
diferencia entre estas dos funciones ya
las conocemos súper bien esta es seno de
pi x y la otra la inferior es x al cubo
menos 4x va entonces si hiciera un
dibujo de un rectángulo ahí te va un
corte es con un rectángulo o algo así
espero que se vea más o menos en 3-d
entonces sabemos que el ancho de este
rectángulo sobre la superficie es la
diferencia entre la función superior y
la inferior entonces déjame pasar ese
rectángulo para acá va a estar lo único
que hice fue separar el corte vamos a
encontrar las medidas de sus lados el
ancho de este rectángulo es esta función
menos esta función en cada punto x es
decir va a ser
no
debbie x
- x al cubo menos 4x y cuál va a ser la
altura entonces lo que nos dicen es que
la altura o bueno la profundidad en este
punto del lago es 3 - x entonces el alto
estrés menos x
entonces el área de este corte va a ser
igual pues el área de un rectángulo es
lado por alto entonces es seno de px
menos x al cubo menos 4x
por el alto entonces es un lado por alto
nos queda
3 - x va entonces ese es el área de cada
uno de los cortes si queremos encontrar
el volumen de todo el lago lo que
queremos hacer es tomar el área de cada
uno de estos cortes e integrar todas
esas claro multiplicadas por de x para
poder pensarlas como volúmenes muy
delgados entonces esta área hay que
multiplicarla por de equis y con esto ya
podemos pensarla como el volumen de una
rebanada de jamón super delgada ya
teniendo esto lo que queremos es
integrar de 0 a 2 déjame poner aquí la
integral de 0 a 2 va una vez más si te
das cuenta esta integral tiene senos y
funciones polinomiales entonces parece
que se puede hacer integral por partes
pero va a ser súper latoso y tal ayudó
como sólo tienes 45 minutos para todos
los problemas entonces vamos a suponer
aquí que quieren que utilicemos la
calculadora entonces voy a sacar la
calculadora una vez más
entonces a ver mira ahí está la parte de
sé que resolvimos hace rato entonces
vamos a pues la cálculo nos permite
copiarla entonces vamos a aprovechar eso
así ya nada más hacemos unas pequeñas
modificaciones la diferencia entre el
primero y el segundo es que arriba está
elevado al cuadrado
y ahora
esta de aquí está elevado al cuadrado
verdad pero ahora hay que multiplicarlo
por 3 - x entonces déjame aquí moverme
para la izquierda borrar este este
cuadrado entonces vamos a ponerle
eliminar y ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar
entonces tenemos que insertar
por abrimos paréntesis 3 menos
y cerramos paréntesis a ver déjame
checar que hayamos puesto todo bien
es expresión de ahí está correcta
entonces hay que integrar con respecto a
equis y los límites de integración es de
0 a 2 va entonces le damos enter
ahí está la calculadora vamos a darle un
rato para que acabe de procesar a esta
nuestra respuesta es 8.369 98.3 7 está
bien entonces el volumen es igual a 8.3
7 bar bueno espero que esto te sea útil
espero hacer cada día algunos de estos
problemas nos vemos en el próximo vídeo